president biden is traveling to kentucky
today to survey the damage left by what
could become the deadliest tornado in
the state's history 74 people are
confirmed dead there but more than 100
are still unaccounted for our lead
national correspondent david begne spoke
to a family who are struggling to
recover after a sudden and unspeakable
loss
this is what their house looked like
before the tornado they were inside when
the storm hit
david is now outside of what is left of
the family home
david good morning
nate good morning you know the only
thing left standing that was here before
the tornado and still is
the stairs leading to the front door
but the door is no longer there
this was a 100 year old home
the mother and her two kids were inside
they wanted to go to the basement there
is one here
but they didn't have time to get to the
basement in fact when the home collapsed
everything fell to the bottom and into
the basement
he was perfect
i didn't always think so but
he was
he was one of a kind that is what huda
aloo bahi wanted us to know about her
three-year-old son jaleel
last friday night the unthinkable
happened
aloo bahi was sitting in the living room
with jaleel and his little brother
julius when she got an alert on her
phone
tornado warning i heard the alarm go off
on my phone and the power went out and
my three-year-old he said um
mommy i'm scared as soon as i heard kind
of like train noises i grabbed both of
them and just jumped into the closet in
the bathroom by that time everything was
just falling on top of us that storm
shredded alubahi's home
bringing the upper floors crashing down
on top of her and her babies i was
under there somewhere
they were penned underneath the rubble
i think it was the sink or the toilet
that's what landed on my face right
there
where were the babies right here
one was in this arm and one was in this
arm
i never saw my three-year-old because my
face couldn't turn that way but i did
see the baby
and he uh cried and then he just stopped
so
at that time i thought he was
oh god
but he wasn't
i never heard my three-year-old say
anything
did you little die in your arms
dude
i'm so sorry
it was actually her youngest son's
screams
that helped alubahi's brother to find
them in the rubble one-year-old julius
was rescued first
and he was untouched by the debris i
didn't know my three-year-old
was gone until
later that night so i never saw him at
all
how did you find out their dad came
when i was in the hospital and he told
me
i wish i could have saved my son
you know the storm that destroyed huda's
home
also destroyed her mother and her aunt's
home just down the way
now huda has three older children they
were at their dad's house just 15
minutes behind this home tornado did
nothing they're fine their home is fine
the randomness scale of how it affected
people here
and you know what david that's all i can
think about is hoot at this moment you
know she has two children one survives
one does not i can't imagine how she's
processing this right now how is she
under the circumstances
she's okay remarkably strong but she did
say she hasn't seen the kids since the
tornado and i asked why and she said i'm
just i'm not mentally fit to see them
yet
i also david can't get over the before
and after pictures of their home the
only thing is you're standing in front
of the steps that's the only thing
that's left of their home that they used
to live in
it's hard to believe gail that
everything you know we talk about storms
partially almost kind of destroy i mean
this obliterated the home there is
nothing but the four steps at the front
yes mother nature is a mighty force
david thank you as always